お金払ってもね尊敬心って得られないん
ですよ努力してる人間のその努力を
ちゃんと報われるようにしてあげたい人は
まず買われるんですよ人を変えることは
できないんですよ青木サの人生経営哲学
100回聞いたら豊かになる
話今回はですね中小企業においてま自分の
右腕だと言える幹部ナンバー2ですねをま
どう育てたらいいかということについてん
非お話いただきたいと思いますうん
なるほど
[音楽]
まずね自分自身がねま相手から見て
やっぱり尊敬される自分かどうかってこと
だよねだからお金払ってもね尊敬心って得
られないんですよこの人のようになりたい
とかこの人のこういうところが素晴らしい
なとかなんて言うんだろうな自分自身が
この人と共に共通の的に向かって歩んでる
ことが自分自身の人生の質を高めることが
できるし喜びにそれが繋がるという風に
思ってもらえるような取り組みって大事
じゃないかなと思うんだよねま実際人の
ことは分からないので僕自身はどんな風に
してきたかって言うとまず本音本心そして
本気うんあとあんたのなやっぱり脂質人
それぞれ10人トなのでやっぱりこう脂質
の高い人間じゃないと高いパフォーマンス
を維持し続けることってできないのでだ
からそういう意味ではやっぱりこの人間は
物になるこの人間は物にならない例えば物
になるってどういうとこで思うかって言う
とやっぱり実行力があるかどうかってこと
だと思うんだよねまず求めてくるかどうか
求めてきてそして実行する力があって
トライアンドエラーで何度もま挑戦と
挫折これを繰り返すかもしれないでも朝鮮
度挫折を乗り越えて初めて成長があって
その先に成功があるだから僕はどんどん
チャレンジさせるタイプですよねでそんな
中で本人がどういう姿勢で仕事に取り組ん
でいるのかまシンプルに目標達成能力そこ
をやっぱよく見て誠実でね精神誠意物事に
取り組んで誠実一路思いやりがあって仲間
のことを本当に大切にしてそしてこの人の
ためなら人肌脱いでもいいと思って
もらえるような人柄を持ってる人間が
やっぱりやっぱり人の上に立ってくんだと
思うんだよそういう人間を僕は目をかけて
きたうんあの分決定的な違いって僕は奨学
金をその取れる人間に奨学金を出すタイプ
なんですよだから怠けてる人間を働きもに
するという努力よりも努力してる人間の
その努力をちゃんと報われるようにして
あげたいっていうことに僕は力を注いでき
たタイプだから10人いても2割に徹底的
にやっぱりこう重点的に指導していく
タイプ平等にはしないんだよねでその2割
が上がってその下の人間をサポートするだ
常に2割で8割の
成果その2割が役員に上がってきたよねだ
からまうちの会社は新卒で入って2人
取締り役になってる人間がいるあと中東で
1人入って今行役になってる人間がいる
けどみんなあのうちの青木はこう考えてる
っていうその僕の大弁ができる人間ですよ
ねということはうちの社長って今何考えて
んだろううちの社長って何を1番大事にし
てるんだろううちの社長は今どういうこと
をでんだろうかって彼らは考えてくれたと
思うで僕が望んでることは企業理念の具現
化ですから上質の追求我が者は選択を元に
した高品質の人材教育を通して顧客の成果
の想像に貢献し全社員の物心両面の豊かさ
と社会の平和と繁栄に寄与するだからその
顧客の成果の想像は価値ある商品の普及に
よってのみなされると思っているのでま僕
はよくアチーブメントピラミッドの一貫性
っていうこと言ってきてるんだ愛はスリー
プレゼンテーションtoデイとだから愛が
あれば1人でも多くの人にあって熱心に
説明をするという行動で完結するはずだと
いうロジックなんだよねだから僕は自分の
部下を愛愛するということは部下を一角の
人間に育てるってことだと思うんですよで
も本人がそうなりたいと思ってなければね
例えばスポーツでもレギュラーになりたい
と思ってない人にお前どうしても
レギュラーになれっていうのは愛とは言え
ないかもしれないただ基本的には
レギュラーになりたいって確認した時に
レギュラーになりたいって普通は言うよね
じゃあレギュラーになるにはこれだけの
大下の先払いが求められるけど覚悟ある
かってありますって言ったら分かったと
じゃあ全部プランを立てようと言って一緒
にプラン立ててあげて一緒になってその
達成を喜んできたそういう僕は上司なん
ですよねうんだからうちの幹部っていうの
はみんな僕の期待に答えてくれてる人うん
だ僕にとっては大切なものすごく大切な
存在なんですよ家族以上とは言わないけど
家族と同じぐらい大切な愛すべき存在それ
が社員ですねで特にその社員の中で幹部と
なったらそれは共通の目的に人生かけて
くれてる人と定義していいわけだから組織
の共通の目的に対してコミットメントして
人生かけてくれてるんだからそり大事にし
なきゃいけないバチ当たるじゃん僕は
じゃあ大事にするっていうことはどういう
ことかっていうと経済的にも精神的にも
豊かにできる仕組みを作って育成の過程で
部下を豊かにしてきた人生それが僕のま
人生だよねそれが今まだ200名ほどの
組織だけどまおかげ様で働きがいアワード
ベストカンパニーも9年連続入ってるしま
今準グランプリも去年も今年も第2位と
いうね100名から999名まこれ決して
自慢話じゃなくてねまうちは全員参加型の
採用してるわけだしやっぱり社員が会社
愛してなかったら全員参加型の採用なんか
できないよね採用って人事がするものだ
なんてみんな思うじゃんうちはそうじゃ
ないもん200人全員が採用に仲間
増やそうとしてるわけだからやっぱり自分
の会社を大切に思っていたり事業の社会性
に対してしてるからじゃないかなそんな風
に思うけどねうんありがとうございますで
も実際その幹部になりたいかって言ってま
なりたいって言うけれどもなんか違う方向
ちょっと向いてたりとか能力が足りなかっ
たりとかなんかそういうことって実際には
あるんじゃないかなとは思ってまして
なんかその幹部になりたいって思うけれど
もなんか本当にこう幹部になってく人材
ってどういう人材でどこで見極めてるん
でしょう
か
あの
ね人はまず変われるんですよ人を変える
ことはできないんですよだ人は変われるん
ですねこれ大前提なんですよでそれを私は
信じてますし能力開発の専門家として
変わりたくなるように情報を提供していく
よね真味になってあとは環境整えて
ます常にその支出かける環境をかける本人
の選択の中でモデルになり得る良い先輩が
たくさんいる組織これが望ましい組織なん
ですよその中で自然にそこを目指してくる
人間に目をかける乾いがるでそこを伸ばし
ていくうんでそれはある意味ではエコひに
見えるかもしれないでも僕はそれが正しい
姿だと思ってます公平
平等じゃないんですよ公成公平なんですよ
だから努力してる人間が報われる社会努力
してる大化を払ってる人間がちゃんと認め
られる会社そういう会社を目指すまた
作り上げていくからこそ育つんじゃないの
人がだあとは忍耐だよね早急にねもく3年
かき8年なんだからやっぱ人によって伸び
方違うんですよ願望の強さも違うし適性も
あるしそこはやっぱり適材適所ですよね
時間をかけてでも経営者は常にやっぱり2
割の人で8割の成果なのでその2割との
コミュニケーションをやっぱり大事にし
なければいけないもう1つは全体最適の
仕組みを整え続けなきゃいけないだから
人事効果もフェアである必要あるあととま
福利構成だとかそれは全員平等です
パフォーマンス成果に対してきちっとした
評価をしてあげるまうちの場合はまね税引
後利益の3割のその利益は社員に還元する
3割は内部法3割は配当1割は社会への
還元
CSRこれを僕は2006年に考えて
ずっと実行し続けてきましたまそれが結果
的にま平均の年収も大企業に負けてない
年収も実現してるしま社員も自分の能力を
開発して会社に貢献していけば自分は
どんどんプロモーションもするしま役職が
上がればそれにふさわしい報酬が約束され
ているのでまやりがいも感じてる見通しを
持たせてあげる能力って上司の責任だと
思うんだよねどうしたら見通し持てる
かって言ったらプロセスがやっぱり資格化
できるってことだと思うのようんどういう
ことをしていったらどうなるのかっていう
ことがそれをうちの場合はもう定期的に
説明会も開くし人事がもうそれを丁寧に
教えてるしイントラネットの中でね
やっぱりそれがきちっと見れるような
仕組みもあるしやっぱりこうなんだろう
報われる組織を作るってことが大事なん
じゃないかなそんな風に思いますけど
[音楽]
ねまず本人がナバ2なりたいっていう人間
かどうかだよねナンバー2になりたくな
いっていう人間をナンバー2にな
れっていうことをしちゃダメなのよだ僕は
ね多分これがね決定的な違いだと思う人を
見て報この人間は何を求めているのかで
もっと言うと人は自分の命を最大に輝かせ
たいと思ってるはずなのでやっぱ事業目的
そのものが社会性があるかどうかま
アチーブメントの場合はま社会課題である
人の不幸感から来る様々な不幸な現象をま
この世からなくしていくことに課題を持っ
て教育事業をやってるわけだよねそのこと
にまずコミットメントしてるそして企業
理念企業ビジョンそして事業計画それを
しっかりと実行して実を作ってけるそう
いう支出がある人間に対し
てま公平構成に人事効果制度をしっかり
作りながら一緒になってその思考を実現
できるようにサポートしてあげることま
うちの役員はやっぱり16年17年と勤め
ていって結局そういう能力が時と共に育っ
ていったよねうんそれは2年は3年で
そんな人材育たないですだからやっぱり石
の上にも3年っていうけど基礎があって
応用があってそしてその上に育成の
マネジメントや様々な課題がこう能力開発
でそういう能力身についていくのでま時間
をかけてでもね面白いなやっぱり本人が
そうなっていくよ
ねうん自分がこうしてあげたいっていう
よりも
本人のそういうなんだろう努力をちゃんと
見てあげるってことじゃないのあのキング
ダムってあるじゃないね我部真大将軍に
なるぞってあれね大将軍大き将軍はさ別に
我部真に特別目かけてるわけではなくて
我部真が一生懸命上に上がってこようと
するそれをていくじゃんだからやっぱり中
にあるのよこの人の中にあるんですよ僕は
やっぱりトップセールスなりたかったもん
だからトップセールスになったしトップ
マネージャーになりたかったもんだから
トップマネージャーになったし若い時16
時間とか働いてたからね俺それ今考えたら
ねそれが良かったかどうか分からないでも
僕は大下の先払いをして自分の能力を高め
てきたことは事実ですだから僕はなんだろ
実績というもの
で自分のポジションを作ってきたうん実績
は裏切らないよそういう人間はやっぱり
引き上げていくしかないんじゃないかな
うんやっぱり支出がうん8割かな正直だ
教育の専門の仕事してるけれども求める心
のない人間を成功させることはできないと
思います昔ね私がコンサルタントで独立し
た直後ねすごい著名なある成功している
コンサルタントの人に成功の秘訣を聞いた
んですよそしたらその人は成功者の
コンサルをすれば成功するっておっしゃっ
たのねでも僕はそん時ピンとこなかったの
なぜかって言うと医者はね病人のために
存在してる
とだから病気の人に対してなんての医者は
力になる問題解決が仕事じゃないかでも
よくよく考えてみたら同じ医者でもそう
いう治療に焦点当てる医者もいるけれど
病気にならない体作りの指導してる医者が
いるんだよねだから成功者ほど成功したい
のよだから結果的に今うちの会社がなぜ
発展できたかって言うとそのアドバイスを
僕は実行したからと思う受行性はみんな
成功したくて来てるからその成功したいと
いう願望を叶える具体的な技術を提供して
きたからアチーブメントは発展したわけ
ですよ成功したくない人を捕まえてあんた
成功しなさいと言ったこと僕はないんだよ
ねだ幹部も一緒じゃないかなやっぱり伸び
てくる人間を絶対その気持ちを無限にし
ない必ずその思考を現実化させてあげる
そこに持って取り組むてことが大事なこと
だとそんな風に思いますけどねうん
ありがとうございますはい是非ねえ今日
学んだことをえこのYouTube見て
いただいてる方はですねコメント欄に是非
ねえどうぞ金入していただきたいなと思い
ますあの投稿をね楽しみにしてますあとは
是非ねえチャンネル登録も忘れないように
お願いしますあの継続をして聞くことに
よって見ることによって必ず豊かになる
思考法が身につきますのでよろしくお願い
します